ces mêmes machines dans un mode différent,
et dans ce mode, on pouvait filmer des flux sanguins microscopiques
de centaines de milliers d'endroits indépendants dans le cerveau.
Oui et alors ? En fait, les changements d'activité neurale dans le cerveau,
qui font fonctionner votre cerveau,
qui font tourner le logiciel de votre cerveau,
sont étroitement corrélés avec les variations du flux sanguin.
On filme un flux sanguin et on obtient
un proxy indépendant de l'activité cérébrale.
Ça a littéralement révolutionné la science cognitive.
Prenez le domaine cognitif que vous voulez, la mémoire,
la planification motrice, le fait de penser à votre belle-mère,
de vous mettre en colère contre quelqu'un, une réaction émotionnelle, etc,
placez la personne dans un appareil IRM fonctionnel et
filmez comment ces variables se calquent sur l'activité du cerveau.
Nous n'en sommes qu'aux débuts et c'est à l'état brut pour certaines mesures,
mais en fait, il y a 20 ans, nous n'étions nulle part.
On ne pouvait pas le faire comme ça. On ne pouvait pas le faire pour des personnes en bonne santé.
Ça a provoqué une vraie révolution et ça nous a ouvert
de nouvelles perspectives expérimentales. Les neurobiologistes,
comme vous le savez, utilisent des tas de cobayes pour la recherche,
des vers, des rongeurs ou des drosophiles, ce genre de choses.
Et maintenant nous avons un nouveau cobaye : les êtres humains.
Nous pouvons désormais utiliser des êtres humains pour étudier et modéliser
le logiciel des êtres humains et nous avons
quelques mesures biologiques en plein essor.
Bon, laissez-moi vous donner un exemple d'expérience que les gens font,
c'est dans le domaine de ce qu'on appelle l'évaluation.
Vous savez, l'évaluation est exactement ce que vous pensez que c'est.
Si vous vous vouliez évaluer deux compagnies, l'une par rapport à l'autre,
vous voudriez savoir laquelle est la plus appréciée.
Les cultures ont découvert le facteur clé de l'évaluation il y a des milliers d'années,
Si vous vouliez comparer des oranges avec des pare-brise, que feriez-vous ?
Eh bien, vous ne pouvez pas comparer des oranges avec des pare-brise,
ils ne sont pas miscibles. Ils ne se mélangent pas entre eux.
Donc , vous les convertissez plutôt en une échelle d'évaluation commune,
vous les placez sur l'échelle et vous les évaluez ainsi.
Votre cerveau doit aussi faire quelque chose comme ça,
et nous commençons à comprendre et à identifier
les systèmes du cerveau qui interviennent dans l'évaluation,
et l'un d'eux comprend un système de neurotransmetteurs
dont les cellules sont situées dans votre tronc cérébral
et apporte la dopamine chimique au reste de votre cerveau.
Je vous épargne les détails mais c'est une découverte
importante, et nous savons pas mal de choses là-dessus à présent,
et même si ce n'est qu'un petit bout, il est important parce que
ces neurones sont ceux que vous perdriez si vous aviez la maladie de Parkinson,
et ce sont aussi les neurones qui sont littéralement détournés
en cas d'abus de drogue, et ça a tout son sens.
La prise de drogues changerait
votre manière d'appréhender le monde. Elles changent votre façon
d'évaluer les symboles associés avec la drogue de votre choix,
et elles vous les font prévaloir sur tout le reste.
C'en est la principale caractéristique. Ces neurones sont aussi
impliqués dans la manière dont vous pouvez évaluer des idées abstraites,
et je donne ici quelques symboles auxquels nous assignons des valeurs
pour diverses raisons.
Nous avons un super pouvoir comportemental dans notre cerveau,
et il implique la dopamine au moins en partie.
Nous pouvons renoncer à tout instinct de survie pour une idée,
pour une simple idée. Aucune autre espèce ne peut le faire.
En 1997, le culte La Porte du Paradis a perpétré un suicide de masse
sur la supposition qu'il y avait une navette spaciale
dissimulée dans la queue de la comète de Hale-Bopp, alors visible ,
qui les attendaient pour leur ascension. Ce fut un évènement incroyablement tragique.
Plus de deux tiers d'entre eux avaient des diplômes universitaires.
Mais ce qui est important ici est qu'ils ont été capables de renier leur instinct de survie
en utilisant exactement les mêmes systèmes mis en place
pour leur permettre de survivre. Ça fait beaucoup de contrôle, non ?
Une chose que j'ai laissée de côté dans cette histoire,
c'est une chose évidente, qui est au centre du reste
de mon petit exposé, et ce sont les autres.
Les mêmes systèmes d'évaluation sont redéployés
quand nous évaluons les interactions avec d'autres personnes.
Donc ce même système de dopamine qui devient dépendant des drogues,
qui vous fait trembler quand vous êtes atteints de Parkinson,
qui contribue à diverses formes de psychose,
est aussi redéployé pour évaluer les interactions avec les autres
et pour assigner une valeur aux gestes que vous faites
quand vous interagissez avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Je vais vous en donner un exemple.
Vous mettez sur la table un pouvoir de traitement si énorme
dans ce domaine que vous le remarquez à peine.
Laissez moi vous donner quelques exemples. Voici donc un bébé.
Elle a trois mois. Elle fait encore popo dans ses couches et ne sait pas résoudre de calculs.
C'est une de mes proches. Quelqu'un va être super fier de la voir ici à l'écran.
Vous pouvez lui cacher un œil, vous verrez encore
quelqu'un chose dans son autre œil, et j'y vois une sorte de curiosité
dans un œil, et je vois peut-être un peu de surprise dans l'autre.
Voici un couple. Ils partagent un moment ensemble;
nous avons fait une expérience dans laquelle on peut découper
différents morceaux de ce tableau et vous verrez encore
qu'ils partagent quelque chose. Ils le partagent en parallèle en quelque sorte.
En fait, les éléments de cette scène nous le communiquent aussi,
mais vous pouvez le lire directement sur leurs visages,
et si vous comparez leurs visages à des visages normaux, ce serait vraiment subtil.
Voici un autre couple. Il projette vers nous
et elle le fait encore plus clairement, vous voyez,
de l'amour et de l'admiration envers lui.
Voici un autre couple. (Rires)
Et quand j'y pense je ne vois pas d'amour ou d'admiration à gauche. (Rires)
En fait, je sais qu'il s'agit de sa sœur, et vous pouvez juste le voir
lui dire, "C'est bon, on fait ça pour la photo,
et juste après tu me voles mon bonbon et tu me frappes en plein visage." (Rires)
Il va me tuer pour vous avoir montré ça.
Bon, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Que nous apportons une énorme quantité de pouvoir de traitement au problème.
Ça met en jeu des systèmes profonds de notre cerveau, dans les systèmes
dopaminergiques qui sont là pour vous faire rechercher le sexe, la nourriture et le sel.
Ils vous maintiennent en vie. Ils ont la meilleure part du gâteau, ça leur donne
cette sorte de coup de pouce comportemental que nous avons appelé super pouvoir.
Et comment le prendre pour arranger une sorte de mise en scène
d'interaction sociale et la transformer en expérience scientifique ?
Et la réponse courte est : les jeux.
Les jeux économiques. Ce que nous faisons est d'aller dans deux directions.
La première est appelée économie expérimentale, la seconde, économie comportementale.
Et nous volons leurs jouets. Nous trouvons un moyen pour qu'ils contribuent à nos propres fins.
Ceci vous montre un jeu particulier appelé le jeu de l'ultimatum.
La personne en rouge reçoit cent dollars et peut offrir
de les partager avec celle en bleu. Disons que rouge veut en garder 70
et qu'il en offre 30 à bleu. Il propose donc une répartition 70-30 à bleu.
Le contrôle passe à bleu et bleu dit ; "J'accepte",
au quel cas il remporterait l'argent, ou bleu pourrait dire
"Je le rejette", au quel cas aucun des deux ne reçoit rien. OK ?
Donc un économiste rationnel dirait, en fait,
vous devriez accepter toutes les offres différentes de zéro.
Et que font les gens ? Ils sont indifférents à une répartition 80-20.
A 80-20, c'est un jeu de pile ou face que vous acceptiez ou pas.
Et pourquoi ça ? Simplement parce que ça vous énerve.
Vous êtes fâché. C'est une offre injuste et vous savez ce que c'est.
C'est le genre de jeu réalisé dans mon labo et dans de nombreux autres dans le monde.
Ça vous donne juste un exemple du genre de chose que
ces jeux testent. Ce qui est intéressant c'est que ces jeux
requièrent que vous ayez un tas d'équipements cognitifs en ligne.
Vous devez être capable de venir à la table face au modèle réel d'une autre personne.
Vous devez pouvoir vous souvenir de ce que vous avez fait.
Vous devez vous lever au moment opportun pour faire ça.
Enfin vous devez mettre à jour votre modèle sur base des signaux entrants,
et vous devez faire quelque chose d'intéressant,
comme une sorte d'évaluation de pensée profonde.
Vous devez décider de ce que l'autre personne attend de vous.
Vous devez envoyer des signaux pour gérer votre image dans son esprit.
Comme pour un entretien d'embauche. Vous vous asseyez dans le bureau de quelqu'un
qui s'est fait une première image de vous,
vous envoyez des signaux de l'autre côté du bureau pour déplacer cette image
de vous d'un endroit à celui où vous voulez qu'elle soit.
Nous sommes si bon à ça que nous le remarquons à peine.
Ce genre d'essai l'exploite. OK ?
En procédant de la sorte, nous avons découvert que les humains
sont de vrais canaris dans leurs échanges sociaux.
Les canaris ont été utilisés comme une sorte de bio-capteur dans les mines.
Quand du méthane ou du dioxyde de carbone s'accumulait,
ou que l'oxygène diminuait, les oiseaux s'évanouissaient
avant les mineurs -- ils agissaient comme un système d'alarme préventif :
Hé, sortez de la mine. Ça ne se passe pas bien.
Les gens venaient à la table et même à ces interactions sociales artificielles
et très éculées, et eux, et il y a simplement
des nombres qui vont et viennent entre les personnes
et qui charrient d'énormes sensibilités avec elles.
Nous nous sommes rendus compte que nous pouvions l'exploiter, et en fait,
quand nous l'avons fait, et nous l'avons reproduit à présent
pour des milliers de personnes, je pense de l'ordre de
cinq ou six mille. Pour réaliser cet essai biologique,
nous avions encore besoin de chiffres plus importants que ça,
bien plus. Mais bon,
des schémas sont apparus, et nous avons pu prendre
ces schémas et les convertir en modèles mathématiques,
et utiliser ces modèles mathématiques pour aboutir à de nouvelles idées
dans ces échanges. Oui et alors ?
Le "et alors", c'est une mesure comportementale vraiment bien,
les jeux économiques nous apportent des notions de parties optimales.
Nous pouvons le calculer pendant le jeu.
Et nous pouvons l'utiliser pour détailler le comportement.
Voilà ce qui est chouette : il y a six ou sept ans,
nous avons mis sur pieds une équipe. A l'époque, ça se passait à Houston, au Texas.
Maintenant c'est en Virginie ou à Londres. Nous avons développé un programme
qui lie les appareils d’imagerie par résonance magnétique
sur internet. Je pense que nous avons lié jusqu'à six machines
à l'époque mais concentrons-nous sur deux d'entre elles.
Ça synchronise les machines où qu'elles se trouvent sur terre.
Nous synchronisons les machines, nous les réglons sur
les mises en scène d'interactions sociales et nous espionnons les deux cerveaux
en interaction . Donc, pour la première fois,
nous ne devons plus regarder des moyennes d'individus pris isolément
ou de personnes jouant contre des ordinateurs, ou encore d'essayer d'en tirer
des déductions. Nous pouvons étudier des dyades individuelles.
Nous pouvons étudier comment une personne interagit avec une autre,
faire tourner le test de nombreuses fois et commencer à avoir de nouvelles idées
sur les frontières de la cognition normale,
mais plus important, nous pouvons tester des personnes ayant
des maladies mentales définies de façon classique, ou des commotions cérébrales,
dans ces interactions sociales et les utiliser pour le tester.
Nous avons donc débuté l'effort. Nous avons fait quelques petits pas,
quelques, je pense, des découvertes embryonnaires.
Nous pensons qu'il y a de l'avenir là-dedans. Mais c'est notre manière
d'avancer et de redéfinir, avec un nouveau lexique,
un lexique mathématique en fait, par opposition aux moyens classiques
auxquels nous pensons quand il s'agit de maladies mentales,
caractérisant ces maladies en utilisant les personnes
comme des oiseaux dans les échanges. C'est -à-dire, nous exploitons le fait
que le partenaire en bonne santé qui joue face à une personne atteinte de dépression majeure
ou joue face à quelqu'un avec un trouble du spectre autistique,
ou face à quelqu'un atteint d'un déficit de l'attention hyperactif,
nous l'utilisons comme un bio-capteur et alors nous avons recours
à des programmes informatiques qui modélisent cette personne et ça nous en donne
une sorte d'évaluation.
Les balbutiements, nous n'en sommes qu'au début, nous mettons sur pieds des sites
de par le monde. Voici quelques-uns de nos sites participants.
Le hub, c'est assez ironique,
est centré en Virginie, dans le petit Roanoke.
Nous avons un autre hub à Londres à présent et les autres
se mettent en place. Nous espérons délivrer les données
à un certain avancement. C'est un problème épineux
de le rendre disponible pour le reste du monde.
Mais aussi nous n'étudions qu'une petite partie
de ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains intéressants et donc,
j'aimerais inviter que ça intéresse
à nous demander le logiciel ou même des indications
sur comment progresser à partir de là.
Je vais terminer avec une pensée.
Ce qui est intéressant quand on étudie la cognition
c'est que nous sommes limités, dans un sens.
Nous n'avons simplement pas eu les outils pour observer des cerveaux interagir
simultanément.
Le fait est que, même quand nous sommes seul,
nous restons une créature profondément sociale. Nous ne sommes pas des esprits solitaires
construits sur des propriétés qui nous permettent de survivre dans le monde
indépendamment des autres. En fait, notre esprit
dépend des autres. Il dépend d'autres personnes,
et il s'exprime dans les autres,
donc la notion de qui nous sommes, souvent on ne sait pas qui on est
avant de se voir en interaction avec d'autres personnes
qui sont proches de vous, qui sont vos ennemis,
ou qui vous sont indifférentes.
Il s'agit en quelque sorte du premier pas pour se servir de cette idée
pour définir ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains, d'en faire un outil,
et d'essayer d'en tirer de nouvelles idées sur les maladies mentales.
Merci de m'avoir écouté. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)